what's up man good to see you how are
you
all right good champ are you
i'm good man nelly is the dude that just
never stops working you're on tour right
now
um well not on tour but yet but we we're
doing like spot dates and things like
that and festivals and uh i think this
one is uh yeah a rodeo
yeah well you don't get to to platinum
and double platinum without that work
ethic we saw you post that picture
of um uh of your single going platinum
there on instagram like do you is there
a wing in your home is there like a wing
in your home for all those things like
where does that look uh
to my mom's house
yeah i'm lucky if i get any of it really
um
i got a few things and then you know we
we spread them out man and um but
majority of things are at my mom's house
um we had a few plaques in the studio
um you know just spread it around a
little bit but majority of everything is
at my mom's house
so mom's the one with the checklist
that's like do you know where this
grammy is do you know where that grandma
is
well she's got all the grammys she
definitely has all of the grammys so
that's awesome
well hey congratulations on a little bit
on the success of that you're going
double platinum pretty soon
congratulations on heartland like this
is this is awesome dude to be able to
say
you know you're
um
you're doing what you love
continuously
and you have people on the album with
you that you know that you've influenced
in terms of how you've been able to
handle your career and do your own style
of music crossing over and all that
yeah
well i mean that's that's
that's because of the fans on the only
way that that comes is that um the
people that have been supporting you
continue to support you and they
and they give you the opportunity to be
what we like to call musically free and
just doing
certain and different things that that
you feel good about but at the same time
they have to understand exactly um what
it is you're trying to get across as far
as the point and the music and they've
been able to do that with me man since
day one so i don't get a chance to do
this project without uh my supporters
understanding
um nelly and his music
yeah for sure you've got um
a lot of really great people
collaborating with you on this kane
browns on there you know
we had this talk a while back but the
idea now that we're kind of busting down
the barriers of what people say this
genre of music supposed to be that genre
of music is supposed to be have you ever
had conversations with these guys about
um
about that specifically and kind of even
from their point of view how you
kind of led the charge in that way
well i don't i don't think we we've
never sat down and just had a
conversation that was strictly about it
i think what the thing is is
we're all doing
what we love to do and for these guys
this is their genre of music exclusively
so to speak this is what they do this is
what they're technically categorized as
but unfortunately
in in in this genre of music it's like
the last genre of music to um
i would say catch up to the rest of the
world as far as um
uh social equality and things of that
nature and allowing um
you know
uh different backgrounds and different
ethnic groups to thrive in that area of
music so to speak it's it's almost
been locked down contingently to
to a certain to a certain type of people
um if you could say that in that way but
the thing about it is that
um if you look at the younger generation
of country music lovers and country
music fans and country music artists
it's almost impossible to find anybody
that's
50 years or younger in any music that
doesn't have some type of affinity for
hip-hop
that doesn't like some type of imbalance
some type of hip-hop artist so hip-hop
is the only music that is technically
went and influenced
in some way shape or form all of the
genres of music you know what i mean and
when you when you when you're when
you're growing
i just think the kids are
you have so many kids that are trapped
between lanes of of
of yeah they love country music yeah
they love this but they also love this
and they also love that and it's the
same on on any other side you have a
gang of hip-hop fans that that
that that have an affinity for for
country music and affinity for pop music
and affinity for all these other music
so
you know i just think the time has come
for people to just enjoy themselves
across the board bro
yeah
do you see as part of your like mission
as a music as a musician
to give younger artists a platform and
this opportunity to express show
themselves off
yeah and whatever you're doing not just
in music but just in life in general you
always want to be inspirational you
always want to help
inspire and and
and help lead the next generation for
those that have come that are coming
behind you that that inspired to not
just be where you're at but also to take
it to a level that you may not have been
able to get to
so i think that's always the goal and in
music
i mean to inspire people that's art in
general no matter that's what the arts
is about to inspire and hopefully people
see what your creativity um
has brought to you they can see it in
there
many collaborators jimmy allen were big
fans of and you guys have got a dancing
with the stars connection you of course
you know famously being on the show he's
going to be on the show how do you think
he's going to do
i think jimmy will be good man i mean
you know jimmy jimmy's got a great work
ethic and as long as he works hard i
haven't seen jimmy dance
that's it i haven't i haven't seen jimmy
dance
but
i know jimmy's a hard worker
i know he's um
he's someone who
who likes to win and i think that's
that's that's what allowed me
along with my fans
to make it as long as i did because uh
yeah it took me a minute to get to get
acclimated to to the regiment and i
think that's just going to be the
hardest part for him is to understand
that yo it can be done but it's going to
take some work man i mean i i again i've
never seen jimmy dance i don't know
jimmy might have some type of ballroom
lessons before so it could be different
you know what i'm saying i strictly
jumped out of the hood of st louis and
tried to two-step so it's
different right
like we've seen the move on stage but we
don't know he could be holding something
back
right yeah i never seen it yeah i mean
you know the things that you do on stage
that's something different i bounce
around on stage but now we're talking
structured dances dances
that are to be done in a specific way
not the dances that you do and you try
to look cool and you're vibing that's
totally different
when you're trying to keep that elbow up
and the shoulders down
that's like the hardest in the world bro
you're talking about strictly form
ballroom dancing form that's awesome
that's awesome yo
so you know we could talk about all the
accolades in the world right influencing
other artists getting all these awards
but sometimes the hardest people to
impress are your own family are you are
you your kids think you're cool do kids
do you think you're a cool guy
i'm being yeah listen um i know
i i'm blessed with beautiful kids that
that love me to death and i love them to
death um now
i think they appreciate what i've been
able to do a little bit more now when
they were younger
i think the only they were impressed
that i knew bow wow
that was the biggest thing to me you
know they're saying like like the fact
that i could call bow wow and chris
brown and have them that like
that i was the best dad in the world at
that time you know
so now that they're a little older i
think they understand um
my work and the things that i've been
able to do uh especially with them um
wanting to be in music a little bit more
now especially my son who's learning how
to produce who's actually who's actually
getting pretty good
um and then my daughter she can she can
do whatever she can sing rap then she
she's she's very talented so i think
they understand it a little bit more now
but when they were younger it was all
about bow wow
amazing it's like
it's the fact that you know people it
doesn't matter what you did it's like oh
i know something yeah no it hadn't
mattered that i was so both of them put
together it didn't matter you don't
understand all they knew is that yeah
dad yeah yeah yeah whatever but uh
where's bow wow
you know
kids man kids
when it comes to their their aspirations
uh musically how do how do you
like are you hands-on with that do you
let them kind of just do their own thing
do they come to you
you kind of got to let them do their own
thing because
when it comes to music i'm a different
person especially when it comes to
trying to teach or trying to listening
like um
you know just because you're a good
student don't mean you're a good teacher
you know what i mean like i'm i'm not
i'm i'm not the best teacher when it
comes to my kids because of the patience
factor and because um
you know i pro i probably am a little
bit unfair when it comes to expecting
them i'm like yo it should be in your
blood i know what are you doing you know
you know what i said and and that's
totally unfair to them so um we we have
a line
that we learned and like yo okay um you
know i kind of walk up as far as they'll
allow me to walk up and when i'm feeling
frustrated i kind of say listen you know
um you may want to ask
you know your uncles which is like city
spud who's also in the group who
produces and writes and you know we have
other writers and producers that that
are in our studio that we work with and
things like that i may send them to
somebody like that because they probably
can explain
a little bit a little bit more than me
uh
but i try i try sometimes we get through
sometimes we don't you know it's that
that love hate
yeah do they do they watch you for your
approval do you do they have like um
i think i think i think they try i think
i think they do
indirectly so to speak if i can say i
think they you know they kind of cut
their eyes to see if i'm bobbing if
they're playing some music
or to see you know and i try to be as
honest as possible i can't be that
parent that whatever they put on it
works because i don't i don't want to
mislead
you know and i try to be uh as honest as
possible and i give them my opinion but
i also let them know that my opinion may
not be the correct one it doesn't mean
that my opinion is right it's just my
opinion
you know what i mean so um
yeah i just try to be as honest as
possible you know
now you you're also coming up with
another milestone dilemma is in the
views club on youtube it's wild it's a
crazy number
is it is it
what goes to your head when you think
man billion people
have seen this yeah
i mean considering that song came out
long before youtube
and you have so many great records that
came out after youtube that has yet to
hit
a million i mean a billion
it's it's just like wow i mean i mean
it's a testament to the music and it's
again it's it's being grateful for the
fans and people loving the record and
loving your creativity as an artist
again that's all you want as an artist
no matter if you're painting
if you're in the music whatever type of
art you are you know that's creativity
that's your thoughts being manifested
into something that you're presenting to
other people for other people to judge
so anytime you do that you make yourself
vulnerable so to be able to do a record
that people see is you know
some people told me you know it's up
there with some of the best records that
they that they love period and that's
all you want